[Music]
hello welcome to another five episode
what's in the box I'm Chuck D flavor
flav we're gonna dive right into this
box find out what goodness awaits
we've given Jason Mewes a knife man that
always means that something exciting is
about to happen
get good at this right they pay for this
sort of thing are we uh oh
let's get these horrible peanuts out of
the way and look at this these are
hateful eight figures that's Kurt
Russell as John Ruth of the hangman they
call him the hangman I thought that was
Bigfoot from the Six Million Dollar Man
hateful eight but there's four only five
one two three four five holy [ __ ] well
done this is I got to imagine this has
to be the first Jennifer Jason Leigh
figure in history which means you could
play Fast Times at Ridgemont High now
you can play rush I don't know if anyone
cares and knows but we had dinner at a
round table with her at the its benefit
we did remember like a picture for
eating she didn't like that your stories
are cute they're just like I've met
Hollywood people they don't like me it's
very very sweet you're right we did sit
at a table with her she was at that
dinner it's very exciting for me at that
point
I'm Scott black I haven't seen the movie
but apparently she plays daisy Dumber or
bill the prisoner here's Daisy domercant
she's wanted dead or alive for murder
and that Sun comes out I'm taking this
woman to hang and this is a Bruce Dern
action figure do you think Bruce Dern is
his entire life ever thought he'd have
an action figure don't know who that is
but that's great
who makes these pictures oh it's NECA
Wow they're pretty damn lifelike this is
one of those movies like I got an Oscar
screener of this movie but I won't watch
it cuz they shot an ultra Panavision 70
on film so you know you're supposed to
go see a movie through people don't make
movies this big anymore nobody really
shoots in 70 millimeter unless they
shoot hole sequences like we saw Dark
Knight wear Dark Knight Rises there are
sections of the movie that were shot in
70 millimeter but not the whole movie
from what I understand Quentin shot the
whole movie in 70 you got to watch it on
film okay that's the thing as old school
it's taking you back to the days where
everything was film it's all digital now
it's all ball bearings these days kids
it's all ball bearings nowadays let me
tell you this is the best part of any
toy do not eat yeah if only they put
this on everything I encounter in life
when we've gotten sick let's open up to
bounty who is the bounty hunters that
Sam Jackson I guess yes Sam Jack got
room for one mo you think he's good
do I think he's a good guy or bad guy no
he's a bounty hunter so the keys guys
robbing colors I'll turn him around man
he's got the yellow and the black look
at that he's got this cool hat too six
shooters I understand it me you and
Quentin are the only people have seen
these toys yeah we got an early look
we're seeing stuff man I told you slow
me I'll take you places yes I'll tell
you what makes me hateful trying to open
these [ __ ] toys
[Music]
I know this is incredibly first-world
complaint but like come on people like I
can't cut these it's made of that wire
[ __ ] yeah this is like opening up a
bunch of loaves of Wonder Bread I don't
know if they still put ties on Wonder
Bread but when I was a kid it always
felt like oh man I can't get this open
fast enough and then you twist it twist
it twist it and you're like it's open
you realize you're just twisted clothes
you know like I'm not eating bread yet
they get their setup the coats and stuff
real fur on hey he's got this one comes
with a pipe like he has a rifle and a
six-shooter that it seems like the
modern-day toymaker really believes in
giving like lots of little trinkets and
stuff like accessories but as a kid who
played with toys I hated all the guns
and [ __ ] because they were too easy to
lose you lose that pipe you're [ __ ]
and I imagine it's a big part as
character you like fighting movies I do
we don't employ Tarantino movies I once
saw somebody on the internet trying to
convince me that like he was not a good
filmmaker which just blew my [ __ ]
mind I'm like look say anything you want
on the internet Lyle you want the one
universal truth we all know Quentin
Tarantino is like the greatest American
filmmaker a lot today without this guy
doing what he did I don't ever do what I
saw Reservoir Dogs and once the cities
see Reservoir Dogs even before I saw the
movie I bought a script at a Comic Con
so I saw the script and I was like what
is it I started leafing through in the
dialogue
it's crazy insane then I want to see the
movie and spell Ponzi matters and it it
was an enabling movie I'll tell you this
much because first few minutes of
Reservoir Dogs they sit around
dissecting a Madonna song she's feeling
son she else is fast pain it hurts just
like it did the first time hence
like a virgin you know I said this
counts like this is movie dialog they're
sitting around talking about the [ __ ] we
talk about all the time maybe not
Madonna but I said this counts this
movie dialogue I think I could write a
movie
so that Quentin man I never get to do
what I do so if people don't like my
shift blame Quentin Tarantino alright so
I open these up I love that each one of
them has a holster that carries their
gun yeah he has a vest he has a tie look
to have little jackets inside I'm
impressed by the food he's got a dish
dude shut the [ __ ] up fat man this ain't
none of your goddamn business
you're not even looking at Sam Jackson's
dick something you always talk about
every moment of every day I wish I could
see Sam Jackson's dick here's your
chance I've been trying to get his pants
off just in like real life when I met up
with them I'm not gonna rest until you
look at what his parents balance okay
yeah the back is shaming Bruce Dern by
showing his heinie cameras he looks like
Metatron yeah
[Music]
see
[Music]
I'm as anatomically impaired as a kendo
the articulation and the detail is
incredible until it comes to the most
important part of a human being
turn around Budi ness down the front
part nothing hung like Jay Mewes they're
all Tucker's five figures of the hateful
eight by five figures yeah
five figures of the hateful eight look
at the detail all right look at the
layers of clothing kids I would say
right off to Goff doesn't wear this much
clothing in real life that can tell us
Tim Roth I could tell this is Kurt
Russell this is almost to stone right
here you're gonna do something or just
stand there and bleed no but I'm saying
but you're saying it's so authentic he
could be used to do any number of Kurt
Russell adventures like you could play
use this figure to play overboard if you
get a Goldie Hawn figure Kurt Russell
doll man could totally play like run and
run and run in the way run run I mean
Tim Roth to the tee I could tell that to
him I don't know this guy otherwise he
probably looks like him but first let's
turn that is a incredible likeness of
Bruce first my song from a distance I
thought it was Malcolm McDowell really
yeah look from a distance hey Malcolm
not at all no okay no how much would you
pay for the hateful five
spiteful five hateful eight is if you
get the other three let's just call
these despiteful five I'd say with the
inner laying of the buttons and the
two-piece you mean the inner leg look
it's on the inside oh no I'm just trying
to I don't know what I'm talking about
these clothes are nice is what I mean
yes cufflinks and how much I'm impressed
with the clothes I like how they look I
give these these are I would say these
are $29.99 I'll give you a hint
you can't buy single figures cuz they're
gonna be just selling the set Oh for the
whole set of eight it is gonna be for
the whole set of eight oh my goodness so
I'm saying $250 the hateful eight when
you buy the whole set grand total three
hundred and twenty-nine dollars what
roughs out to about $40 a piece but come
on let's be honest this isn't for
children I got guns and stuff like that
stretchers go up on a shelf and never be
taken out the box man
the clothing though right I really I
think this the clothing the detail the
faces I'd give these a thumbs up if
you're a collector of toys favorite
Quentin Tarantino movie mine yeah give
it some serious thought man well cuz I
really like killed Roger Ebert I like
Kill Bill a lot but and then I'm
thinking up but I don't wanna see Pulp
Fiction even that was fun because I
think that's everyone's favorite alright
it's a reason there's a reason for you
bill I'll go Kill Bill which one I like
both combined that's cop-out answer
right there not only transmits cop but I
mean you got to pick one well I want to
say - but you said - so I'd say to our
camp no you didn't I say to - is my
favorite oh you're copying me
one of the greatest moments of my life
was I made a movie called red stay at
Michael parks Senate Michael parks is
Quentin Tarantino's like one of his
favorite actors of all time
no branch count so we went to Quentin's
got a movie theater like we showed 35
millimeter movies at his house and we
went and watched the movie there and if
you ever want to feel good about
something you've done in life you share
it with a stoned Quentin Tarantino man
it's enthusiasm beyond enthusiasms
pretty amazing I remember this is this
this was an amazing part for me a moment
I guess I think we were in London where
we had some Foust Awards place you and I
were the apart yes and I remember he
came up and he said oh my god man you
were awesome in the tripper
little indie movie that I didn't think
that he'd ever see and he saw it and you
said I was amazing anything you blew in
Clark's but tripper no it was amazing
and again but I was so nervous and like
sweaty cuz he came off music hey bro you
were great in this and I was like what
movie talking and I threw up and [ __ ] I
had an erection him then and then it
went soft so so nervous Quentin loves
cheese and things that aren't
necessarily liked by everyone else that
gives me and you a shot he's very good
at finding the gold and the big pile of
cheese I like that as a smart guy it's a
diamond in the rough look at that we've
got something here nobody else has man
again the only people have seen these in
the world right now are me and you and
Quentin himself approving these figures
and you saw here on what's in the box
baby he's got a point man what's in the
boxes weak this [ __ ] Bruce turn
figure Sam Jackson I'm never listen this
is crazy this is the world we live in
Bruce Dern figure lie to me is Tim Roth
come back next week man will take more
things out of things you want to see us
pull things out of a box
we'll pull anything out of anything just
write to the screen junkies on their
Twitter account we're at their Facebook
page you're probably at the address
somewhere below here let them know what
you would like to see us open up for
what's in the box I'm Kevin Smith
Jimmy's and we found out what was in the
box and was this stuff we'll see you
next week on the box what's in the box
so we're done what's in the box
[Music]
you